cela devait être une grande fête du
football
elle a tourné au fiasco
on a payé pour être là j'ai un ticket
le match c'est longtemps joué à
l'extérieur du stade entre ceux qui
tentent d'enfoncer les grilles et des
policiers qui répliquent à coups de gaz
lacrymogène
c'est tellement éloigné de ce qu'on rêve
de ce qu'on a imaginé depuis si
longtemps il faut garder beaucoup
d'humilité parce que voilà ces images là
elle date de pas très longtemps on est
très aujourd'hui à l'écoute de tous ces
signaux de dérive potentiels on a
décortiqué tout ce qui s'était passé
donc voilà il y a un certain nombre de
d'enseignements qui ont été précieux
pour nous
et on va voilà faire en sorte que ça
n'arrive plus
[Musique]